millions of Brazilians had overlooked
Jade Watson arrows misogynist and racist
comments his religious fanaticism is
adoration for guns during his election
campaign because they believed he would
wage a war against corruption but no
longer on the same day that Baal Sanada
replaced the country's most popular
anti-corruption Crusader former justice
minister said gemoro with his personal
legal adviser the Supreme Court blocked
his pick for federal police chief
another close friend of the family the
court argues the appointment would allow
both senado inappropriate influence over
law enforcement bohlson ro is under
investigation for alleged political
meddling in police probes it's
particularly sensitive since two of his
three sons are also being investigated
for embezzlement running a fake news
network and other misdeeds the three
deny any wrongdoing
the president whose middle name is
messiah is also trying to brush off the
soaring number of deaths from Kovan 19 I
lament it but what do you expect me to
do a messiah but I can't do miracles
people waiting to receive emergency aid
for the pandemic were outraged like
Marcello Cara Bologna when he says so
what at more than 5,000 deaths it shows
a psychopathic character a person you
can't trust he continues to be crazy
he's a new emperor nero of the world i
don't have much more to add also not as
popularity has been plummeting since he
fired the health minister for trying to
promote social distancing measures now
with the death toll surpassing that of
china brazilians have good reason to be
worried about their presidents legal and
political problems detracting from the
more pressing issue of keeping
brazilians alive you see a Newman
al-jazeera